The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's
start to discuss ion traps.
Now, in many situations, ions
are just charged neutral atoms.
And if the charge
doesn't matter,
you can do very similar physics
with ions and neutral atoms.
However, the charge
makes major differences
when it comes to confining
and manipulating particles.
So when I compare
neutrals to ions,
the forces which we
exert on neutral atoms
are magnetic forces,
optical forces.
And typically, the
traps we can create
have a depth of about 1 kelvin.
Actually, you just need
superconducting magnets.
The magnetic traps we build here
at MIT have millikelvin depths.
So the trap depth is
often on the order
of microkelvin, millikelvin,
and kelvin at the high scale.
Well, this is very
different in ions.
In ions, you have
the Coulomb force.
If you take electric fields
of 100 volts per millimeter,
you can create confinement
forces for 10,000 kelvin.
So you have no problem in
confining room temperature
ions.
When it comes to-- so this
is trapping and confinement.
If you talk about cooling,
well, our workhorses
are Doppler cooling and
evaporative cooling.
You can actually cool
ions by evaporation.
You can also cool ions
by evaporative cooling.
But what has been very
common and special to ions
is the ability to resolve
sidebands, sidebands
of the vibration and motion in
the harmonic oscillator trap.
And in problem
set number 10, you
have looked through the
physics of sideband cooling.
However, sideband cooling
is now also coming back
to neutral atoms.
For instance, if you have
neutral atoms in a very tightly
confining dipole trap,
you can resolve sidebands
and use those for cooling.
OK, what is the science?
Well, a driving force for
both ions and neutral atoms
has been clocks.
If atoms are cold,
you can use them
to have very accurate
ways of keeping time.
And I think currently,
there is a race
between the based neutral
atom atomic clocks,
neutral [INAUDIBLE]
optical lattices,
and ion traps in particular,
the aluminum ion at Boulder.
So we have clocks.
In ions-- and this is what I
want to talk a little bit more
about today-- a major driving
force was quantum information.
You have two ions and get
quantum gates between them,
or you have eight
ions and can have now
eight qubits in a
prototypical quantum computer.
So quantum information
science and quantum algorithms
was quite important.
But I would say
some of the physics
is at least discussed
and partially pursued
with atoms in optical lattices.
We have talked a lot
about, for neutral atoms,
quantum simulations,
studying super fluidity,
studying phase transitions,
magnetic properties
of many body systems.
But there are more efforts
to do that with ions.
Chris Monroe's
group in Maryland is
studying antiferromagnetic
ordering of a spin chain.
And the spin chain consists of
a string of ions in an ion trap.
So see actually on
the science side
that all three-- clocks,
precision measurements, quantum
information, qubits, quantum
algorithms, and quantum
simulation of many
body systems--
are done with both
neutral atoms and ions.
So these are now two
very different platforms.
So I could spend a
long time teaching
about special aspects of ions.
How do you do a trap?
How do you cool ions?
How do you do quantum
state control?
Because this is
our last lecture,
I decided to focus
on two aspects.
One is, I want to talk about a
special way of trapping ions.
Because there is one
difference for ions.
Ions, until recently,
have not been
trapped in stationary traps.
They've only been
trapped in dynamic traps.
So you cannot trap ions by
simply putting an electric
potential around it.
Because the divergence of
the electric field is 0.
And that means there's
always one direction in space
where the ions are dragged out.
You cannot have an inward
force from all directions.
So therefore, when you want
to use electric fields,
you can only use dynamic traps.
Well, for the
experts I should say,
this does not apply for
the optical dipole trap.
We know how we can create
trapping potentials
for neutral atoms using
the optical dipole trap.
And very recently, a group
was able to trap ions
not with electric and magnetic
fields provided by electrodes
or radio frequency, but by
inner focused laser beams.
So it's a very new development.
But it uses exactly
the mechanism
which has been used
for neutral atoms.
So when it comes
to dynamic traps,
the standard two
traps which have
been used for ion trapping--
one is the Penning trap,
which I do not want
to describe in detail.
The Penning trap uses a
quadrupole configuration
of two positive charges.
And then you have a ring
with negative charge.
That means that an
ion is confined here
but would see anti-confinement
in the outward direction.
Now, what you do with
the anti-confinement?
Well, the solution is that
you add a magnetic field.
And what happens
now is the particle
is well-confined axially.
But radially, when
it wants to move out,
it's turned into
a cyclotron orbit,
and therefore stays trapped.
So this is the principal
of Penning traps
where the confinement
in the axial direction
is electrostatic, and
the confinement in x, y
is through cyclotron motion.
OK, it's wonderful
physics to describe
the motion of ions in this trap.
It's the combination
of an axial motion,
cyclotron motion,
magnetron motion.
It's very interesting physics.
And for many years, Dave
Pritchard here at MIT
used such Penning traps to
measure the masses, determine
the masses, of ions with
the highest precision ever
possible.
MIT still has the world
record of the most precise
mass measurements at the
10 to the minus 11 level.
And this was done
in Penning traps.
But I want to talk more today
about RF traps, or Paul traps,
because the are used in the
majority of experiments.
And they're used in pretty
much all experiments
on quantum information
processing with ions.
So the neat thing--
and I try to teach you
concepts in physics-- the
interesting thing about Paul
traps or RF traps is that
you alternate at a radio
frequency between confinement
and anti-confinement.
You can say you have a
settle point potential, which
is confining in x and
anti-confining in y.
But then, you switch x and y.
So therefore, the situation
is just imagine you're an ion,
and you feel half of the time
a confining harmonic oscillator
and half of the time an
anti-confining harmonic
oscillator.
The question I have for you,
and this is a general physics
question, well, is
the sum of a confining
and an anti-confining potential
of the same strength give 0,
or does it give something
which in the end is confining?
So if you were in a potential,
and the potential switches
permanently form parabolic
upward to parabolic
downward, at any given position,
the average force is 0.
Because in one phase, you
have a force to the left.
In the other case,
you have the opposite.
You have the same
force but to the right
with the opposite sign.
But what's going on here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I can't answer
this mathematically or even
physically.
But I just remember
this very cool example
that someone showed me once
where they took a saddle shape
in space, put a
ball in the middle,
and then you spin the saddle.
And as soon as the ball
tries to fall to one side,
the saddle will spin
over and pick it up.
So I know the answer has
to be, it is confining.
But I can't explain why.
PROFESSOR: OK, Colin?
AUDIENCE: Could it possibly
be like a threshold?
Because if you consider
spinning it sort of slowly,
then the particle can
just sort of roll off.
Maybe there's a threshold.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
there is a threshold.
I mean, if there's a
confining potential
for a long, long
time, and then there's
an anti-confining potential,
and I just fall down
the anti-confining potential,
and I disappear to infinity,
the confining part
doesn't help me.
So there will definitely
be a threshold in time.
We have to switch between
confining and anti-confining
sufficiently rapidly.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does it
have something to do
with fictitious
force [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, but this would
have been a possibility.
Maybe there is a formalism.
But the standard formalism does
not use the rotating frame.
Let me--
AUDIENCE: You could think
of the classical analog
where you have a bead on a wire,
and you have a stable position
at sort of a finite angle
only at certain frequencies.
PROFESSOR: Yes, I'm not sure.
Anyway, you all-- I think
everybody here works
with optics or knows
what optics is.
So why don't I
discuss the following.
If you take a positive
lens and a negative lens
with equal strength, what
happens now to your laser beam?
You send a laser
beam through, it
gets an inward bend by the
convex lens, an outward bend
by the concave lens.
Is the net effect nothing,
or is it focusing?
Well, it depends.
What happens is the following.
If the lenses are put
in close proximity,
the two bending actions on the
rays just completely cancel.
But now we can do the following.
We can put the two
lenses further apart.
And now the following happens.
We have a laser beam
which is bent inward.
And you probably all know
the lens maker's equation,
that the further
out the rays are,
the more they have to be bent
inward to come to a focus.
So what happens is those
beams are now bent inward.
But when they reach
the other lens,
they are now bent
outward somewhat.
I'm not very accurate
in my drawing.
But the angle by
which they're bent
inward is proportional
to the separation here.
The angle by which
they're bent outward
is proportional to
the separation there.
So the inward bend is stronger
than the outward bend.
So therefore what
I'm telling you
is convex and concave,
with a certain distance
between the two,
results in focusing.
Now maybe you can
think about it.
What happens if I reverse
convex and concave?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Is it
now still focusing,
or is it the opposite
of the example above?
Now the first lens bends
the beam outward, yes?
And the second lens
bends it inward.
But since we reach the
second lens further out,
the invert kick is stronger
than the outward bend initially.
So therefore, when you have
positive and negative lenses
of equal strength, no matter
in what order you apply it,
you always get an inward force.
So this should
actually explain--
AUDIENCE: As long as they're
within the focal length.
Could you imagine if I
had positive and negative
that was larger than
the focal length away?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
everything within reason
here-- there will be
a stability diagram.
But I want to first make it
very plausible what happens.
And just to address the
question which I raised before,
if I'm in a potential,
and I get an equal amount
of inward and outward force,
shouldn't that average to 0?
The question is how you average.
If I would keep the distance
from the x as constant,
I would say here as a function
of-- let me call it x.
The bending angle as a
function of x is positive.
The bending angle at
the same x is negative.
So if I would do the average
at constant x, I would get 0.
But what I do is I do
the average following
the trajectory of the beam.
So in other words,
if I'm sitting
on this potential, which
switches from attractive
to repulsive, if I would
be here at my position,
the average force is 0.
But when the potential is
repulsive, in 1/2 cycle
I'm pushed outwards.
And further out,
the attractive force
is now stronger
than it was before.
And therefore, if you average
the force at my position,
you will always find
an inward force.
But if you average the
force at a fixed location,
it averages out to 0.
So this is exactly
how RF ion traps work.
And well, the rest are just
equations to describe that.
So I think we have
to make a choice.
I could derive for
you the equations, how
you average over the rapid
oscillations of the potential,
and you get a harmonic
oscillator potential,
and this is how you trap ions.
But it's pretty
much showing to you
how the concept I've
just explained to you
is reflected in equations.
Or the second option we have
that takes about 20 minutes
is to explain to you how
quantum computation is
done with two
ions, in particular
how the famous
Zoller-Cirac gate works.
Do you have a clear preference?
AUDIENCE: Second one.
PROFESSOR: OK, fine,
but there is one piece
of mathematics you
should understand.
Really, and this
is the only essence
of the mathematical derivation.
If I'm standing here, and I
feel the alternating force,
it's a cosine omega t,
and it averages to 0.
But if the force drives
me, it shakes me.
This is micromotion.
Like the beam here, if you
go through many lasers,
the beam goes up and
down, up and down.
This is micromotion.
The micromotion is
at cosine omega t.
And the net
attractive force comes
because the force which
oscillates at cosine omega t,
and I'm oscillating
at cosine omega t,
then you get cosine
squared omega t.
And this gives you
the net force which
provides the net
attractive force.
And it's the cosine square term
averaged over the micromotion,
which is one half, which is
responsible for the trapping
potential in ion traps.
Anyway, you know the
physics very well.
You understand where the math
comes form in that it's really
just the product of the two.
It's a rectification.
It's an alternating force.
But since the system
itself, the particle itself,
is driven at the micromotion,
there's rectification going on,
which leads to the
cosine squared term.
[? Timor, ?] yes?
AUDIENCE: Two quick questions.
So I think ion trappers always
complain about the micromotion.
But in fact, they
need it for trapping
to work-- is pretty much
what's going on here, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes, actually,
the one interesting side
of the mathematics is the
micromotion is kinetic energy.
The harmonic
trapping potential is
nothing else than
the micromotion.
In other words, if people
show in an ion trap
that you have a
harmonic oscillator,
the harmonic oscillator
potential is high here.
But mathematically, this
harmonic oscillator potential
is the kinetic energy
of the micromotion.
In other words, if you
look at the micromotion,
it has a kinetic energy.
The kinetic energy appears
as the potential energy
in this slow secular motion.
So in other words, the
potential energy for the trap
is the kinetic energy
of the micromotion.
So you can't avoid it.
This is responsible for
the restoring force.
AUDIENCE: Is it a really
conservative trap,
or can I have an out
of phase component
to the micromotion response?
Is there like a sine
part to the response?
PROFESSOR: Well, the secular
motion is conservative.
You're now asking--
AUDIENCE: I'm trying to think
if there would be a reason why
my response, my
dipole response, would
have a different [INAUDIBLE].
Is there a reason?
PROFESSOR: Well, to the
best of my knowledge,
everything is
wonderfully conservative
if you have a
separation of timescale.
If you want to sort
of get something
strange and non-conservative
out of the micromotion,
you have to violate the
adiabatic separation
of timescales.
There is a possibility that
if particles move quickly
through the
potential, they're not
following the micromotion
adiabatically.
And then there is a
collision where micromotion
is released as
collisional energy.
But on the similar
particle level,
it's a pretty good
approximation.
OK, we want to talk about
quantum computation with ions.
[INAUDIBLE] has a
wonderful write-up
on the wiki on the basic
concept of quantum computation
and how it applies to ions.
But let me immediately
jump to qubit operations.
You've heard many, many
times that a general quantum
algorithm can be constructed
out of single qubit
rotations and two qubit gates.
Single qubit rotations
are just oscillations
on the Bloch sphere.
If you excite a particle, move
it around on the Bloch sphere,
this is how you can rotate a
single qubit from ground state
to excited state, any
possible superposition state.
So the physics of single
atoms, Rabi oscillation,
rotation on the Bloch
sphere, this is all you
have to know about
single qubit operations.
The interesting thing is how do
we create two qubit operations?
And two qubit
operation would mean
you want to do something
to one ion here depending
what the state of
the other ion is.
And this is much more subtle.
So what I want to
explain to you now
is the famous Cirac-Zoller
gate, which was really
a pioneering paper which has
thousands of citations now.
Because it showed that
quantum computation
can be experimentally realized
in a rather straightforward
way.
So it's a fundamental theorem of
quantum information processing
that if you have single
qubit operations, and one
to qubit gate, which is
a CNOT gate, that this
is a universal set
of quantum gates,
any arbitrary quantum algorithm
can be constructed out
of those gate operations.
So let me just remind you
what the CNOT gate is.
We have qubits ion one, ion two.
They can be in 0 or 1.
These can be two different
hyperfine states.
Or in the case of the calcium
ion, it can be the ground state
or metastable excited state--
just two different states
of ion one, two different
states of ion two.
The CNOT gate would
now say the following.
The first ion is
the control bit.
And whenever the
control bit is 1,
it flips the qubit,
the second qubit.
If the control bit is 0, it
does nothing to the second ion.
So therefore, the table
which shows how the quantum
states perform is
1, 1, 0, 0, 1, 1.
It just shows that
I'm writing down
the matrix in these spaces.
It's a truth table 0,
0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 1, 1.
And it shows that when you
have 1, 1 at the input,
you get 1, 0 at the output.
If you have 1, 0 at the input,
you get 1, 1 at the output.
Well, the two qubit
gate I want to discuss,
which can be realized in
the simplest possible way
with the Cirac-Zoller algorithm,
is the controlled phase qubit,
which has a truth table
of 1, 1, 1, minus 1.
And it means it simply
changes the face of the two
qubit states when
both qubits are 1.
Now, the CNOT gate
can be constructed out
of the controlled phase gate
by having two single qubit
rotations done with
the Hadamard gate.
The Hadamard gate is taking
the bases 1 and 2 and creates 1
plus 2, 1 minus 2, the
symmetric and anti-symmetric
superposition state.
So therefore, the CPHASE gate
is S general as the CNOT gate.
Because one can be used
to construct the other.
So how do we create
the Cirac-Zoller gate?
So how do we get now
the controlled phase
gate out of trapped ions?
So the effect is the following.
Remember, if we
have two ions, we
want to change the phase
to minus 1 of the state
only if the two
ions are qubit up.
So in other words, we want to do
180 degree rotation of the wave
function, but only
if both ions are up.
And the question is,
how do we do that?
How does one ion feel what
the other ion is doing?
And let me explain that now.
The critical element in
the Cirac-Zoller case
is a center of mass motion.
We want at some point-- say
when this ion is spin up,
we swap the quantum
information from the ion
to the center of mass motion.
In other words, when this ion
is up, we use laser pulses.
I will explain that to you.
Then all the ions
are moving together.
And then, this ion,
because they're all moving,
knows that this ion
was spin up before.
So the center of mass motion,
the common dipole oscillation
of all ions together in the
trap, this is the data bus.
So this is the key idea.
But in order to explain it to
you, I have to go in two steps.
So let's just take that as
a genetic level structure.
We have an S state.
And it has two different
hyperfine states,
spin up and spin down.
And these are our two qubits.
There may be a P state, which
we have used for laser cooling.
But everything is in the
ground state of motion
using sideband
cooling, which you've
studied in your homework.
And what I want
to show you first
is how we can
create a phase gate.
But I'm only
focusing on ion one.
So hold the thought.
Ion two will come in a few
moments, will come back.
So what we can do
is the following.
Each qubit state has vibrational
structure-- ground state,
excited state without
center of mass motion.
But then, as a function of
vibrational quantum number
for the center of
mass motion, we
have g1, g2, e1, e2, and such.
And what we can now
do is, let's assume
we have another state,
a D state, which
is an auxiliary state here.
Fortunately, ions and
atoms have many states.
And we can drive a
laser transition from S
to D, which is only in resonance
with the first vibrational
excited state to the D state.
So we use a [INAUDIBLE]
sideband here,
which only drives the
transition from e1
to the non-vibrational state
of the auxiliary state.
And that means automatically
that this laser does nothing
to e0, does nothing to
g0, does nothing to g1.
So if you have this Hilbert
space of g0, g1, e0, e1,
the only transition
which is effected here,
or the only state which is
effected here, is the e1 state.
OK, I'm talking
about a single ion.
I'm just talking about talking
to a single ion right now.
It's really simple.
So if we switch on this
laser, what happens
is we simply induce Rabi
oscillations-- simple physics.
The Rabi oscillation,
however, after one Rabi period
has changed the phase of the
initial state by minus 1.
If you carefully look what
Rabi oscillations are,
the wave function goes
up, down, up, down.
But we usually discuss what
happens to the probability.
And this is shown in green.
So when we are back
in the original state,
we have changed the phase of
the wave function by minus 1.
So let's just assume that
we switch on this laser
to this auxiliary state,
and we have a-- well,
it's a 2 pi pulse in population.
But it makes a phase shift
of pi to the wave function,
which is minus 1.
So what we have
accomplished now is
a phase gate not
between two ions.
But we have a phase gate
which, in this Hilbert space,
between the qubit
up, qubit down--
I call it ground
and excited state.
But the other
qubit, so to speak,
is the center of mass
motion 0, 1, 0, 1.
So this is the truth
table of the phase gate.
And so technically, we have
now done a local phase gate
with one ion where
the two qubits are
ground and excited
state of the ion.
This is our qubit we
want to work with.
But then, the second qubit
to realize the phase gate
was 0, 1 of the center
of mass vibration.
But once we have
realized that, we
can now immediately
take this idea
and get a phase gate
between two ions.
Because the center of mass
vibration is everywhere.
So therefore, what we can
do is this was ion one.
We can now-- and this
is the missing step
I want to show
you-- go to ion two.
And we can swap the qubit
information-- ground, excited,
spin up, spin down.
We can swap that with the
center of mass motion.
So therefore, what we can do is,
when the second ion is spin up,
we do a swapping
of the information
from spin up, spin down
to center of mass motion
being 0 or 1.
So the idea is the following.
Ion two should control
what ion one is doing.
So we first focus on ion two.
We swap the qubit of ion two
into the center of mass motion.
Then, we do what I just
said, the controlled phase
gate for ion one with the
center of mass motion.
And after this is done, we write
the center of mass motion back
into ion two.
And then we have
nothing to ion two.
Ion two was just
putting its information
into the center of mass motion.
It helped ion one to do
the controlled phase gate.
And then, we swapped
the information back.
So this is the sequence.
After preparing the center of
mass, the first of two lasers
cool everything in the center
of mass motion into the 0 state.
Then we swap from ion
two the information
to this phonon state
center of mass vibration.
Then we do the controlled
phase gate on ion one.
And then, we swap
the information back.
So what I should show
you-- you may have seen it.
But what I should
show you explicitly--
how do we swap
the information ge
from the internal
state of ion two?
How do we write this information
into the data bus, which
is the phonon,
which is the center
of mass vibration in the trap?
Well, we again use
[INAUDIBLE] side pulse.
We do a pi pulse
driving this transition.
And just look how beautifully
the math works out.
We have an arbitrary
qubit state,
a superposition of
ground and excited.
And the center of
mass motion was
laser cooled to
the ground state.
So let me just
multiply that out.
So we have coefficient a times
g0 plus coefficient b times e0.
If we now do a pi pulse, we
transfer the population from e0
into g1.
And this is what I've done here.
But now you see I
can factor out the g.
And what I have now is I have
the same qubit information
with coefficients e and b, but
no longer in the internal state
of the ion but in
the phonon state
in the qubit, which is
the center of mass motion.
So the idea here is you can have
an arbitrary number of ions.
And now you want to
have a quantum gate.
What you do with a
quantum gate, you say,
I want to now take this
ion here and have a quantum
gate with 10 ions further down.
So you first go
to your first ion,
transfer the information of
this qubit into the data bus,
into the center of mass motion.
And now with a local
operation here,
you can do something to this
ion conditionally on the motion,
the center of mass motion.
But the center of mass
motion reflects the ion
over there, in
which state it was.
And after you have
done the two qubit
operation between
those two ions,
you take the center
of mass motion,
put it back into this ion.
And at the end of the
day what you have done
is you have done a
two qubit operation.
You've changed the
state of this ion.
But all the other ions
have remained the same.
And with that, you can
now, in a chain of ion,
implement arbitrary
two qubit operations.
I think I said it
clearer in words here.
It is in a little
bit more formal way
the steps you will do
to the wave function.
You initialize.
Your transfer the
information to the data bus,
you execute the
controlled phase gate,
and you put the information
from the data bus
back into the control ion.
And now your data bus
is free, is back again
to the initial value and
ready for the next operation.
I should mention that
this was pioneering paper.
Right now, this quantum gate
is not the most popular one.
Because it has
severe requirements.
One is you really have to cool
to the absolute ground state.
The center of mass
motion has to be
cooled to the
absolute ground state.
There are other
quantum gates which
do not require such
extreme cooling.
And secondly, the center of mass
motion, because all particles
move together, is one of the
slowest vibrational motions
in the system.
And if you want to
scale up the system
to more and more particles,
the speed of the gate operation
has to be slower than
the vibrational period
of the center of mass motion.
So these are two disadvantages.
But there are different
gates, like geometric gates,
like Sorensen gates.
There are other possibilities
to involve the same quantum
logic with ions.
But the one of
Cirac-Zoller really
stands out by it's pedagogy.
It's really a
wonderful way to see
how we take the information,
put it in a data bus,
do the controlled
phase operation,
and then proceed to the
next two qubit gate.
OK, so that's the end of
ions, the end of this class.
Do you have any questions
about the last topic?
If not, let me say thanks.
You were a fabulous class.
I really enjoyed the
classroom atmosphere.
I enjoyed all the
questions, whether it
was after class or during class.
And, well, I'm happy
that most of you
I will see around for
a number of years.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]